[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on everybody it's Sean
oven through first we feast comin at you
from lower Manhattan where I'm joined by
a familiar face I'm Matty Matheson right
there I'm Matty Matheson there's a good
intro Matty is in the building you can
catch him in season 3 of dead set on
life which returns to vice land on
Thursdays and we're not going to be
eating scorching hot chicken wings today
instead we're getting real Canadian with
it it's poutine showdown 2017 we're at
Mile End if you want a great taste of
the great white north and NYC this is
the place to be at poutine bowl verse 13
bull Sean Evans vs. Matty Matheson may
the best man win you ready to get it
going let's get it let's get it so we're
eating poutine you know which everybody
thinks of is you know this Canadian
delicacy but I want to talk about
Montreal specifically because that's
sort of ground zero for poutine it bears
home just like the poutine - Montreal is
like the po-boy in Louisiana or you know
the pizza of New York
poutine to me is fries cheese curds and
chicken gravy that is poutine is there
such thing as a poutine snob are there
people who are up in arms when you put
foie gras Lobster absolutely but then
that's where the creativity comes that's
where people's like cravings come out
people may think it's over the top but
it's the traditions it's the culture
it's if there's cold winters gross
snowmobiling hunting for wolves right I
come home and they want to eat foie gras
big great pieces of meats and french
fries you know like it is the culture
leave a Quebec baby
[Music]
Maddie what are you going to be cooking
up you know a little restraint
I got lobster foie gras beef tenderloins
I'm doing just a classic cheese curd
chicken brain being everything kind of
melting together really nice mouthfeel
this mouthfeel the poutine is very
important the lobsters done via for
eight minutes and that eight minutes I'm
going to cook a beef tenderloin you want
to do like almost like a medium sear no
medium-high heat so then it doesn't get
like that well done charred thick crust
kind of do it it's beautiful there's
been a minute look at that that's what
you're looking for that's a beauty right
there
a little bit of lobster tail a little
bit of claw meat once again mouth filled
cage one little there we go okay
okay Shawn beautiful right we is that
nice Hall sir that's a great lobster I'm
a little feeling a little nervous
we got the foie gras I'm just going to
break it up into little cubes oh yeah
it's like real-life animal butter it
just becomes like moldy little anxious
tube tubes of beautiful duck liver there
it is sweat on my balls we're going to
make a poutine this is it the second
attack
holy [ __ ] we got some Lobster we got
beef tenderloin then we got a beautiful
little foie gras he did this is how you
make the best [ __ ] poutine you've
ever had where daddy's in the kitchen
cooking better just set the table enjoy
yourself so I'm going to make sort of
breakfast
poutine that's sort of a hangover cure
get real sort of Midwest with it is
everything else ready like maybe you
should cook your bacon first that's
usually how it goes in the kitchen town
oh yeah just like trying to dress your
child on a snow day I'm not afraid to
lose I'm not afraid of competition I'm
willing to help my good friend Sean you
know hopefully I just want beautiful
food to be made don't know who wins or
loses like hopefully I win hopefully
Noah has the tongue in his mouth
will realize what the hell is really
going on I don't know about Sean and
he's doing with his raclette and all
this garbage you got from a fridge
Sean good luck all I want is that like
that's all I know is that so now is that
cheese a cheap slice that cheese that's
all I know about this okay so when we
put the cheese on high BAM cheese is on
ahh
well it dad there's talk like that okay
I'm gonna buy up to do this bourbon yeah
okay it looks ready look at that
yeah laughs okay well that is what that
is what I'm talking about okay
go there and talking about the whole
reason there you go
I get it this dish is basically look at
this one scene right here take a look at
that up stop on the tour shop then just
BAM look at that Oh a little bit of a
fail here's what I'm going to say it
might not look like I wanted it to look
but this is going to taste amazing chef
Evans and a half eight hey
Mamma Mia little caramelization
little crispy knit what does I don't
have kitchen game I see right now it's a
modern art sort of situation like a
jacquard bob [ __ ] over here whoo
chef Evans our main man Oscar in the
back he's having fun with this it is I
like this mmm oh my god I love it
that looks good we have my dish
Shaunie's poutine Chinese poutine we got
Manny's poutine Hannity's poutine I
think no one's going to be really
impressed you put a fried egg on there
it's not going to add any viscosity it's
not going to add anything super you know
just a hard-cooked egg I like that's
good you like that yeah no don't runny
yolk I like that you went hard on that
that's what you do I like that you are a
little bit longer hardens up
all right let's go ahead to hell all
right
[Music]
all right we're here at the table and we
have the owner of Mile End here a
Montreal native Noah is going to judge
the dishes we have Maddie's poutine
where Shaunie's poutine accepted very
simple
I think the mouthfeel getting really
nice I'm in a little bit of a different
route
you know the mouthfeel it's not going to
be hungry and to him no no I love it all
about just putting the layers in and I
know that looking at the dish you might
be like Jesus what the hell happened
here
I think I think that's where I'm going
to win you home right about further ado
visually yes
I'm drawn to Maddie's dish I'm wearing
my life that he plated it right to the
ads very modern plating there's a little
bit of a creative plating you know
that's right
modern perhaps yes I'm going to start on
the left side now
I like smoke me also should be pretty
easy
well yeah it's your smokes me I feel
like you might be biased for that one
because it's all yours this is all your
meal plan I have to try the rest of our
Channel yeah it's like a protective
shield over the trench prize so now so
I'm just gonna tackle I got a warm
blanket
yeah it's like dry on dry it's nice
straight a little bacon bacon girl
because 9 out of 10 for interesting I
like where this is going so this is a
little bit of a surf and turf you know I
like it you got your your cooked lobster
your your tenderloin your little foie
gras and the most feel is like
everything will is almost the same
consistency with the chair and our mouth
feels really nice if you'd be getting
different flavors different different
structure but as you'll see it's very
cohesive rather than there this works
together I feel I just like a
deconstructed to achieve you know layers
yeah layers take it on the part with a
compliment you can shop with units one
of them pleased to get explained
differently
mady's - however kind across an alliance
- both being an interesting night
looking and also noises so if I have to
check I wanted to put on the menu
drumroll
if you cut would pick Maddie yeah but
that's what you know you he's a pro you
know anything good I got Stacy none
wrong with that like yours if your
animalistic like we are about food like
you'll find this good as you know like
animals whose you know lick their own
genitals like so you know if I thought
our life our club
what well I think that when your boob
gets compared to an animal flicking its
own balls I think that's that's pretty
much a good place to end you know dead
set on life season three come into vice
land on Thursdays you already know Mile
End to the poutine it's the place to be
if you're double YC
[Music]
do you like Fargo I do I do I left one
girl good for mouthfeel it's good
mouthfeel mouth you know feels very
importantly food